enfin non mais t'as pas changé c'est
toujours aussi jolie je me tais tu es
toujours aussi flatteur c'est sam c'est
son petit mais que thébaux mon poussin
savate et pas trop fatigué tu as dormi
un peu pendant rien j'ai checké c'est ce
film ça atv j'ai pas dormi et d'un tri
je me suis comme un soupir on est
contents vous soyez là tu peux tu sais
c'est que voulait aller dormir chercher
m
airbnb joseph non mais oh je voulais pas
vous déranger c'est tout mais non mais
vous restez là je te préparer une
chambre et je fais les boulettes vous
n'êtes pas dicter sa telles sont les
boulettes les courses
j'adore les boulettes et vous avez la
vidéo il joue en ma ligne sommes égaux
dgo wigan est en ligne
oui oui bon à un moment j'ai cru qu'il
avait les deux pieds dans la tombe entre
la vie et la mort joseph plus près de la
mort ça c'est joseph va ton pc
d'exagérer ça c'est marseille ça aux
attentes à oublier toi aussi tu es
marseillais pas parce que tu mets des
chemises à carreaux côte est américaine
non canadiens et américains canadiens et
américains
c'est pareil non c'est pas pareil joseph
d'être canadien ou d'être américain fois
le même pays
c'est pas le même loin mais c'est pas
pareil d'avoir une bosse sur la tête et
d'être bourran pas parce que l'asiatique
était bouddhiste d'avoir été le cerveau
si la parité dire n'importe quoi
justement non je te reconnais pas mon
temps avec ce but avait deux ans c'est
sur une photo que l'acheteur maintenant
j'ai des âmes
12h20 comme ton cousin sam sam c'est
dégoûtant cousin l'asn ségo c'est quoi
ça c'est qu'un hibou c'est comme ça
qu'on tchèque le canada au cc un pastaga
non je prenais un risque est plutôt moi
comme les cowboys whisky la classe